hey guys this is dennis the founder
thank you and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and this is our review of agents of
shield episode 6 electricity so before I
watched this episode I got a lot of
tweets and facebook messages saying hey
this episode is awesome this episode is
awesome like because you know a lot of
people have had mixed feelings i hate
the show some people like me and you are
like mixed about it so finally when
after watching it i have to say i liked
it i think it's the best one they've
done so far hmm i don't think it was
amazing or anything but it's a step in
the right direction a small step in the
right direction i will give it credit it
was a small step in the right direction
but i'd be curious to hear what people
think about what part they liked the
most for me it wasn't the whole thing
with fitzsimmons and the you know i
can't remember which one is which was
almost dying i don't that didn't grab me
because i don't think they've earned
that scene yet because we don't have any
contact with those two characters but
some of the conversations between
towards an opinion and Agent Coulson
were that was a very good moment there
were some very good conversational
moments I think have been missing some
character building moments that we
didn't need in this in this episode well
I think the reason why I liked this
episode much more than the other ones is
the tone ya own of this episode is a lot
different than all the obvious ones it's
a much serious that is not darker but
there was you know right much more
dramatic there was like danger to know
where before we really it was just kind
of like who gonna save today right now
right um and also it wasn't really that
focused on on sky is the main character
you know you know she was definitely in
it but like it seemed more of like okay
this is a group thing right yeah I mean
it was good I the moments were better
the conversations because that's the one
thing I've been griping about a bunch is
that I want character development with
these guys I mean it can be funny it can
be dramatic whatever but I want
something to care about and uni the
point with fitzsimmons and the
near-death experience that didn't quite
get to me
because I just don't know those
characters I don't have an attachment to
them but I thought it was very powerful
towards the end with mingyuan that
dislike just just kind of you know them
just like you know it's looking like a
look you are different you are chains
like this really horrific scar that you
have like you are a different person
that was nice I did like that moment
yeah and also I I do like the moments
between Fitz and Simmons just you know
getting a little more back history of
them their relationship and what you
know what he was willing to do for her
go in there like basic no sacrificing
himself the nominee was better than this
the other bench I like this this week we
do well I think the banner is better
because instead of just like banter
banter banter time you're spacing it out
between dramatic stuff right and
therefore that makes it better because
you can't just do it all the time no no
and it's good i mean we know that event
i think i'm not sure if it's next week
of the week after we are going to get
episodes going to tie into thor the dark
world so this shows moving I'm not sure
what the show wants to do is still early
you know it's still early but I want to
know I'm still not sure what the show
wants to do overall like what's the
what's the big story the season yeah we
don't have that I mean we with this
storyline it was tied into the whole new
york tonari alien thing kind of reminded
a lot of people of a fringe episode you
know right right yeah they found
something and they got investigate and
and then they'd you know something
someone's in danger and that was nice to
tie tie that back in with the whole
sheet re thing like I said that this if
this is a sign of things to come I'm
down more than I was last week when I
was getting really for I guess two weeks
now frustrated with the show and was
like I just don't know what's gonna go
anywhere but this episode was better
it's a step in the right direction yeah
cuz it's tied into a main storyline that
we know and I just felt like the tone
was better yeah like I said it's not the
ship has not turned around no not an
amazing show is that but if they can
take what they've done in this episode
and keep building on that know with that
same tone and character development no I
think it'd be a lot better you know yeah
I think it will be i mean i guess to
tell you know think your community just
you know stay tuned keep watching I mean
definitely go see Thor this weekend when
it comes out and then come back
hopefully with an episode that's gonna
tie in somehow we'll see yeah I also
heard that Thor 2 has
two endings but yeah yeah 2 plus n make
sure you stick around for that so I know
what do you guys think of this episode
was this the one that like turn
everything around over you was it
awesome or you maybe you already loving
the show no you know it just works for
you anyways personally I thought it was
a small step in the right direction it
was better it needs a lot more of that
and a lot you know yeah just in general
for me to be start being able to like
recommended right now I can't recommend
the show to anyone no I wouldn't be like
you have to watch this show i mean like
i said i'm watching the first season i'm
in it but yeah i don't know if i can
recommend it yeah alright guys you can
post your comments below on the website
think CARICOM or make sure you subscribe
to our YouTube channel think hero pro if
you wanna come chat with us a come find
us on Twitter went out with a dentist
Michael any of us on think here or here
we're at think hero I'm at Griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and share and
tweet our videos you know that what the
word yeah
you